abrirían estos referendos una nueva
etapa en la guerra es decir si Rusia
reconoce estas zonas como su territorio
podría alegar que está siendo atacada
con armas donadas por países de la otan
Yo creo que es precisamente lo que busca
Vladimir Putin ahora porque
todo para todo el mundo es claro que el
ejército ruso ha sufrido unas pérdidas
importantes que está perdiendo la
iniciativa en esta guerra pero con el
cambio del estatus de estos territorios
Rusia ahora puede decir que está
defendiendo su propio territorio y como
sabemos también hay unas preparaciones
dentro de Rusia que tiene que ver con el
cambio de la legislación rusa pero todo
indica que realmente va a haber algún
cambio importante en las dinámicas de la
guerra hoy se esperaba un discurso del
presidente Vladimir Putin a la nación
rusa sobre el tema sin embargo se
pospuso qué podemos esperar del líder
del kremlin cree que se tratará de una
especie de ultimátum Occidente
pues es muy difícil saber realmente lo
que es detrás de esta demora del anuncio
de Vladimir Putin las versiones
oficiales que estaba esperando en las
zonas horarias de Rusia cuando la gente
estaré despierta Yo creo que no son muy
creíbles posiblemente en el último
momento hay unos ajustes a este discurso
pero yo creo que todo indica que lo que
va a anunciar Vladimir Putin es el apoyo
a este referéndum y este es el mismo
modo soperante que Rusia estaba usando
para el anexo del territorio de
crecimiento Entonces yo no no creo que
aquí vamos a ver muchas sorpresas en el
contexto del anuncio de los referendos
el parlamento ruso aprobó mayores
castigos contra los militares que se
pasen al bando enemigo se prepara el
kremlin para una movilización mayor de
sus fuerzas incluso para declarar por
primera vez el estado de guerra
yo creo que hay que prestar atención al
hecho que hay varios cambios que tiene
que ver No únicamente con que van
realmente ver las penas mayores para
alguien que no hace caso decimos a las
autoridades rusas sino que también por
ejemplo hay unas penas que tiene que ver
con la producción de alarmamiento que
dentro de Rusia y Que obviamente Ahora
tiene un déficit de las armas
disponibles para poder continuar la
Guerra sin embargo yo creo que para
Vladimir puchen para poder anunciar una
movilización trae unos riesgos muy
significativos porque hasta este momento
el trataba de mantener el público ruso
la opinión pública rusa si bien
inmovilizado en términos del apoyo para
la guerra pero la mayor parte de los
rusos todavía no sintieron el impacto
directo de lo que está pasando en
Ucrania Entonces sí puede ser un riesgo
muy grande para Vladimir Putin y yo creo
que él va a pensar dos veces antes de
hacerlo